it's great to welcome to the program
today PE Moskowitz the author of the
case against free speech the First
Amendment fascism and the future of
dissent also author of how to kill a
city gentrification inequality and the
fight for the neighborhood so great to
have you on today I appreciate it
thanks for having me so to start with I
think most of us have some concept of
the idea of free speech even if it's not
directly from the law of the
Constitution the First Amendment or what
is existing in in precedent and Court
decisions where do you think that our
general concept of free speech comes
from at this point in time is it more
social and cultural rather than a legal
framework I think that we have a kind of
very convoluted understanding of what
free speech actually means and what the
First Amendment actually means and you
know it's kind of drilled into us very
early we learn about the First Amendment
obviously in school from a very early
age but the the kind of rhetoric of free
speech and and yeah this culture of
freedom of expression is used again and
again by you know you see it on TV you
see its politicians saying oh this is
what makes America the greatest country
on earth and you just hear these kind of
platitudes over and over again
all the time I mean and once you start
noticing how much you hear it then
you'll realize that it's happening all
the time but I I think there that's a
diff there is a difference between
hearing this this kind of platitude
about we have freedom of speech every
single day of your life versus actually
learning what it means or whether we
actually have it is there a particular
distortion or incorrect understanding
about what we mean when we say free
speech that is affecting the political
discourse right now that you can
identify I think there are a couple of
them the first would be that people
think freedom of speech applies to you
kind of everything they want it to and
yeah you know in the in the framers of
the Constitution and the amendments
Minds it just applied to the government
um being able to stop your speech or not
being able to stop your speech so you
know people will always you know you see
this on college campuses for example
someone will get disinvited from college
and people will say oh that's a
violation of freedom of speech no it's
not because the government was not
involved in any way you weren't being
arrested for speaking or anything like
that and that you see it all but you
know if someone gets banned from Twitter
people will claim that's a violation of
freedom of speech put Twitter's a
private company and can do whatever it
wants the other the other misconception
I think people have is that we have
universal free speech in this country
which we just simply don't I mean I
can't wander into your house and say
whatever I want in some states you could
shoot me if I do that if we're gonna
stand your ground state I can although I
guess arguably to steal man that
argument it wouldn't be necessarily the
saying of something in someone's house
but the fact that you entered uninvited
I guess that would be you know open the
door to a self-defense shooting right
sure yeah but that kind of proves that
we've at value some things over freedom
of speech
ie private property and and privacy and
you know same thing if I go into a
Walmart they can kick me out for
protesting on their historic grounds
because we value the idea of private
property over the idea of freedom of
speech so when we talk about freedom of
speech what we're talking about is
speech that isn't impinge by the
government is on public property or your
own private property doesn't violate
copyright laws doesn't threaten anyone
and you know even in once you tick all
those boxes you can still be arrested
for protesting you can still be you know
denied a permit to protest by the
government the idea that we have
universal freedom of speech it once you
start looking into it just it kind of it
strikes me as ridiculous that we even
have universal freedom of speech it's
also sort of become a proxy to other
political battles in a sense I mean a
lot of the questions around the right to
refuse baking a cake for someone on the
basis of where what kind of an event
the cake will be used at the idea of
being able to wear political clothing
while working at a particular
corporation for example a lot of these I
guess I could let me ask it to you are a
lot of these really issues of speech or
are they issues of something else where
free speech is being used as a proxy to
try to make a political statement I
think that freedom of speech can end up
kind of you know mucking up what's
actually happening a lot of the times
and yeah you see this with you know
Nazis marching on the streets of the
United States for example in liberals
saying well we have to defend their
right to march because of freedom of
speech because of the First Amendment
and and there are a couple things I
would say to refute that one every other
Western democracy doesn't have a First
Amendment and and gets along fine in
terms of freedom of expression they
recognize that there's no Universalist
kind of platitude that they can that
they need to use in order to guarantee
democracy they recognize that some
things like hate speech based on race or
gender and those kinds of things might
end up doing more harm than good if
spoken without being challenged and you
know I don't think anyone would consider
Canada for example any more of a failing
democracy than the United States is and
they do that without the First Amendment
and the other thing is yeah I mean I
think we can use freedom of speech to
allied these much stickier issues if we
say well I just fed Nazis right to March
because of freedom of speech we end up
not asking why are there Nazis marching
on our streets we end up not asking why
are people denying baking cakes for for
gay people it's it's a way to kind of
live and let live with these really
terrible issues that we shouldn't live
and let live we should be asking why are
there Nazis on our streets we should be
asking you know why is there
discrimination gate against gay people
and instead we just say well they can
say whatever they want yeah I mean I
think that so there's a couple things
that are mixed in here one is obviously
the idea that all
the fact that someone may not
necessarily deserve being proactively
stopped from speaking doesn't mean we
need to go number one out of our way to
make sure that there are no consequences
to their speech free speech when it
exists also is not does not entail
freedom of consequences to that speech
but to make them more practical I mean
so ok with the straight Pride Parade
that we had in Boston a couple months
ago I talked about this because we shoot
out of Boston I said that without even
getting into should the permit or have
been granted or not because you can sort
of take different positions on that to
me the ideal thing would have been that
just no one pays attention that the 60
marchers or whatever show up and they do
their thing but it doesn't look like no
one cares and it's just kind of a waste
of their time I thought might be a way
where we don't even have to have the
argument about free speech but that's
not everybody's approach I mean what
would how do you think those types of
events should be handled I think that
they're I mean there are couple of ways
you can look at that I agree that maybe
no one should pay attention but in that
case I think that also you know the
government shouldn't pay attention to
them either ie dedicate many resources
like cops and you know barricades and
all of this I mean I've been you know as
a reporter and as an activist I've been
to many far-right marches where it's
five you know neo-nazis or whatever it
may be and they offered cops surrounding
them and if you even if you listen to
like people on the far left who you know
want to punch those Nazis in the face or
whatever they're not saying don't let
them Nazis March they're not saying the
government should arrest them or
something they're just saying why is the
government spending thousands and
thousands and thousands of dollars
protecting them when you know if I go if
I go out on the street and say some
ridiculous stuff I don't have police
protection guaranteed and so yeah with
the straight pride people I think there
would be a lot less people marching in
the streets spouting white supremacists
or anti trans or whatever slogans if
they didn't know that a thousand cops
would be there protecting them
that's true and I mean it so this is
where it's sort of like a chicken-egg
thing because I agree 110 percent with
what you're saying and yet if it wasn't
known that there would be more
protesters than marchers or whatever
there probably would not be resources
mobilized and that's not a defense of
anything by the way just to be clear it
sort of becomes this self-perpetuating
thing where if no one paid attention you
probably wouldn't really need resources
because it'd be 40 people walking down
the street and then going you know to
chick-fil-a and getting chicken
sandwiches and going home or whatever
the case may be uh yeah I mean I think
for one the Internet in general has made
us all closer in this bad way yeah I
think we need to respond to everything
you know like Nazis we're still
organizing before Twitter existed but
now I just see them organizing all the
time right so so I think that's given us
the sense of immediacy that's not really
healthy like oh we need to be there we
need to be counteracting this at every
single moment that being said you don't
want you know not to used to go
unchecked on your streets I think if you
allow twenty Nazis to march then there's
nothing to say that in you know six
months a hundred Nazis won't be marching
on your streets and so on and so on I
think there's an argument we've made
that the less you protest these things
even if it is just five people you know
purchasing some ridiculous cause the
less you protest them the more you kind
of allow people to think they're
socially acceptable and allowed that to
grow unchecked so so yes I understand
not not responding to every single one
of these ridiculous protests and kind of
Fanning the flames but at the same time
I think that sometimes it is important
to show that this is not a a socially
acceptable thing to do yeah it's it's
sort of a I mean it's the same decision
I make when I decide is this particular
extremist or am I better off ignoring
them or are their ideas becoming
mainstream enough that it's actually
worth responsibly challenging them and
there's no sort of like guide
necessarily sometimes it's a judgment
call right there is no hard and fast
rule and I think that's really important
to recognize you know a lot of the book
and I should say this isn't just like I
think a piece of a book like this is a
reported book I go to Charlottesville I
go to Washington DC I go to Standing
Rock I go to like five different college
campuses to interview people about you
know blocking conservative speakers
there and when I was on those college
campuses I think you know the students
get this totally unfair representation
of oh they just want to cancel all
speech that they hate but they're
thinking about this tactically to their
you know when it comes to charles murray
the guy who invented the bell curve when
it's kind of like a modern-day Verrier
scientists they thought that he
specifically was worth protesting
because he was taking these far-right
racists concepts and pushing their oh
man a very important conversation with
PE moskowitz that is someone doesn't
want it to happen because we are having
significant connection issues with PE
that may be as far as we can get with it
so I will remind you that we've been
speaking with PE Moskowitz author of the
case against free speech the First
Amendment fascism in the future of
dissent
we will do what we can to try to get PE
back but certainly something going on
with our connection today causing a
major major issue for which I can only
apologize we will take a quick break and
be back with much more right after this